and then your your position changes
because once you have that product
market fit
it's you really you have to execute on
the go to market
and so you have to start bringing in
people who will be better than you
with the sales because your position as
the sales leader
is is over welcome to 20 minute leaders
just sit back relax and learn from the
leaders of today
it's a journey each one is different
unique inspiring
let's get started
this episode is powered by jventures a
community driven vc found in silicon
valley
in partnership with lomi tech and
sponsored by hippo insurance
touring opposed labs and hillel at
stanford if you want to see hyper growth
meet asaf ezra co-founder and ceo of
granulate
telpyot program alum assaf continued his
idf service as a commander in the elite
8200 intelligence unit
he previously held positions as r d team
leader and product
manager where he led 30 plus researchers
engineers and analysts and large-scale
projects
co-founding granulate he hopes to
democratize performance
and build a world without performance
loss assaf ezra so good to see you here
thank you for joining me
thank you for having me i'm really glad
to be here i'm used to see you with an
army uniform but it's
it's a little bit of a different
environment now and i think what you're
working on with granulate is just
is just fascinating obviously i'm not
the only one that thinks that
having been prompted for for all the
incredible fundraising you've done and
the incredible product that you've built
and
i have to say that i i took some time
going through the team that you're
working with and it's some of the most
brilliant people that i've ever met
one by one and a lot of familiar faces
there so you've built a really
incredible team
uh asaf it's such an incredible journey
that you're on
and i don't wanna waste too much time
talking so can you take me back all the
way to your childhood
how do you even get started with
technology programming you and your you
you find yourself in that field
how does that all how does all that
happen well that's uh
that's actually a very interesting
question i i haven't been asked that uh
throughout my journey i'll be honest um
i think what started it was uh uh
going to a boarding school uh for high
school
in uh jerusalem really yeah it was uh
uh it's called the israeli arts and
science academy
um and the the truth is
you're sort of surrounded by a lot of
people who are a lot smarter than you
and everyone wants to learn so it's uh
it's
some somewhat between competitive and
very educational
um so so you get a lot of really
smart guys trying to teach you what they
know you're
working find yourself working from eight
in the morning to three a.m
at night and so it's
it's very driven uh
to success and and thankfully uh
i i was i was not the brightest kid in
my in my class i think i think one of
the brightest
was uh daniel gabba who's a co-founder
of trigo with his brother
and yeah so we we we actually didn't
go to the same uh courses so he he took
physics i took chemistry and so
uh yeah and and i was really lucky to
get into topio
um and uh but but to me
the fact that he got in was was like a
no-brainer
um so obviously you had a very different
upbringing than a lot of other uh high
schoolers not just in israel but in the
world right i mean it's it's
definitely uncommon in the us but it's
also very uncommon in israel
do you did you miss out on things
haven't gone to a boarding school that
is so specialized and
it is not necessarily competitive in the
bad sense of the word but very
motivating to see
a lot of people that are doing some
really cool things and you want to be up
to par with them
yeah i think that's that's actually an
advantage in in my opinion like
you you you get to the place where being
called a geek
is actually a cool thing and everyone
would like to be called a geek
and you you get to see all these amazing
stuff that you can only
uh you couldn't probably imagine uh
beforehand because
it wasn't the same environment um what's
the same
inspirational ideas that you're taught
skill actually gives you like
one week a year where you do whatever it
is that you want and they give you
funding for it which is
uh wow so so i'm pretty thankful for the
opportunities that i had
and uh i i would probably recommend
everyone who has the chance to to do
that because
it's such a a huge leap from
where i was before to to where i ended
right and so you go to top field which
is probably the most luxurious
um place to go in the army because it is
a
i believe a nine-year program where they
take you through
both academic curriculum incredibly
intensive
academic curriculum and then you are
placed in some of the most
incredible places for thinkers in the in
the idf
where you get to use those skill sets so
you go into tokyo tell me a little bit
about this experience and this is
obviously very different than
having gone through tolpio at 18 than
even a lot of what my friends are
experiencing you know at stanford and
harvard
which is might be the equivalent of of
sort of help you but it's still a very
different experience i'd love to hear a
little bit about how you
went through it uh so i
i wish i could give you a romantic story
i think i think all of my
my journey would be very weird like that
but the truth is
i was uh i was kicked out from top here
um
the first time uh four months in
they they let me go due to uh
health uh issues i have a low blood
pressure
and and so i went to unit 81
which is was uh sort of published and i
think you could see in the paper that
yeah i'm part of that boom that uh
that 81 has created uh i i appreciate
that
that inclusion but i don't think i i had
any contribution to that
um and so i actually joined the
the cohort below the one that i joined
and that's where i actually met my
co-founder um
i think i think it was at the second
year of the program that you do
uh projects in teams and you're the only
ones who knew how to program
in that team and we were working crazy
hours
and we said this would be really cool if
we could do that for a living
like working together on our own crazy
ideas
and uh and we we
pretty much there decided that this is
what we wanted to do
uh obviously we were two kids with
absolutely no idea what it means to
start a startup or what it means to do
that but it was the
really early days of everything and we
really enjoyed
working together and uh i think we were
lucky enough to be
stationed in 8200 not in the same
department but
close enough so we were still working
together and
consulting with each other throughout
our service so
for us it was a good start to the
journey i'll say
so i have to ask yourself just quick
questions when did you
work what how old were you when you were
working with him for the first time
with intel pyot 20
and how old are you now when you started
granulate with him
when we started granulate we were uh or
at least i was 28
uh he's a year younger so i just want to
make it a comparison here because you
know
going through you know seeing the you
know the the
young entrepreneurship scene at stanford
a lot of people are starting on their
own ideas and
and obviously everybody talks about the
importance of the team and the
importance of the
of the founding team and i think that
it's just inspiring that you know with
an eight-year gap
although having gone to the same unit
not having been in the same projects
but going back to that experience where
you found a person that you
collaborated well with and you enjoyed
spending those countless hours
and eight years later you come back to
start your own venture together
i think that's that's inspiring and i
think it really suits into the
this mentality that at the end it is
about the founding team and it's and
if you find somebody that you're really
passionate about working together
and then then you hold on to that even
if there's an eight year difference in
that
and it sounds to me like that was the
right decision on both of your parts
i i think it's actually more
embarrassing than that we were uh
roommates in in a year in in the
in top yo and then we were roommates
like flatmates
uh afterwards while we were serving at
we're practically a married couple
i love that asaph so you you finish your
service you
you do so much to to defend our
beautiful country israel
and and now you are creating an
incredible startup
one of the fastest growing and that i've
seen you know with
some of the most incredible investors on
board and and a phenomenal team
and you're really tackling a challenging
problem that i think most people
reading the description on the website
wouldn't even be able to piece together
really what you're doing because
because it's all about you know
optimizations it's about
you know cloud technology which although
it's been there for a while
i think that now we're seeing a surge of
of groups that are trying to optimize
and from what i'm saying in your case
studies it looks like you're doing some
phenomenal things
so tell me a little bit about granulate
and how do you even come to this idea
having gone
working primarily on on-premise servers
so now i i think i think uh the truth is
we we we owe a great deal to
to yl and the program that we did there
uh we we
got out of the army as you probably know
with zero knowledge of what's going on
in the outside world
and as you mentioned cloud technologies
containers
kubernetes whatever um
but the truth is they helped us
understand what a customer interview
looks like what a user journey looks
like
how do you extract information from the
customer when you talk to him
without selling him anything right
because the truth is we had
nothing to sell um and
throughout our meetings something that
came up over and over again was
that uh every
or almost every company was running at
anywhere between 10 to 40
utilization and they had a really hard
time getting that
to to the 80s 90s without
encountering a lot of performance
degradation latency spikes
or whatever and then this could
reach all the way up to to denial of
service
and so it made sense that if that's the
trade-off
then everyone would be running over
provision because i'm happy to pay for
uh for the stability for the slas or for
whatever
but the more we we researched that
with uh design partners who allowed us
to sort of experiment with their own
uh their own system we we saw that if
you're running a 20
utilization and you cut your
infrastructure in half you didn't run at
utilization like things were running all
over the place
um so we started looking into that and
and once again i wish i could tell you
like uh
this romantic story about what we found
out but the truth is we started from the
easiest place that was for us which was
the load balancer
um but very early on we realized that
uh the truth is from a go to market
perspective
trying to install a load bouncer in a
company is
is really hard because a lot of
companies say
okay let's assume that pxe goes really
well
you save us 40 50 of our infrastructure
or this specific service
what happens next like am i going to
trust you
with this entire service what happens if
you need to upgrade your server what
happens if there's a bug
do i experience denial of services like
a small part
that's the weakest link or could be the
weakest link
and it has
no availability or highly available
um so you're you you might end up
with a super strong technology a really
good poc results
but you're not going to be installed
right
luckily we were sort of uh
the the companies were very honest about
the feedback
and we were sort of receptive to that
and they told us
if you could do the same thing on one
machine i wouldn't mind risking one
machine for
the gain that i'm supposed to extract
right i'm already running
very over provisioned so if that machine
fails that's
fine and if i see that it's stable over
time i'm going to increase that
installation
and ultimately probably
install it on all my production
and we were really lucky that this
happened and we were even luckier that
we had
such a strong team to to be able to do
that to take that
and and create something that might not
be possible
to create gains of
tens of percentages on a single machine
but
i really want to to pause here on this
point because i think this is something
that a lot of
early stage founders are tackling
especially those that are running on on
security cloud optimization oh okay
light turned off we are back a lot of
those that are running on on cloud
optimization
and infrastructure and security because
at the end you're building this
technology you assume that it works you
test it locally but then you have to go
and you have to get your first customers
right
and you don't necessarily have you know
the the case studies already and the
customers are already
your champions and you have to go and
the only real way to test it is to
actually be
inside the company and to and in your
case you know route packages one way or
another or or
do the upgrades one way or another was
it difficult getting those first
customers is it based on relationships
based on trust
how do you even get to that point
especially as a first-time
um entrepreneur so here i think there's
something very unique in israel
um like everyone you talk to really
wants to help
um and it's true for people who are
potential customers and it's true for
uh founders so everyone really wants to
put you in touch with people that would
help you
get there so this could be a startup
that's one uh
level ahead of you raised series a maybe
and and they could be your uh your
design partner
very small one towards an installation
and a bigger one
so that the truth is we were very lucky
that people really wanted to help and
this was something that they said look
if you can solve this for us this is
actual money
and it's very tangible and we'll be
happy to see
any results um so i think this is the
way we started and when we started
talking to two people we realized that
uh
load balancer wasn't wasn't gonna cut it
and we we switched to that thing that
would run on a single vm
and then people the same people that
told us about the the
the load balancer were very happy to
get us back jump on the conversation
again
and talk about this new thing that
you're doing they didn't care that
we told them that this was what we were
doing then like a couple of months later
uh we changed it because this is what
they wanted we were very
attentive to their requests right and it
sounds to me like
first of all that that is i think one of
the single biggest challenges of
of young entrepreneurs of truly trying
to find that product market fit
and not just going with whatever
assumptions you had starting on and i'd
love to also
hear from your perspective of running
this company as
you know a young entrepreneur yes vast
experience in the technology field
and a great academia but but now you
know in in
the physical world with startups how
does your position as a leader
shift as you're so quickly growing the
company
because it seems to me that every
fundraising round every new hire
your job changes a little bit right so
what is some of the thought process
that's going on in your mind right now
as you're seeing this company boom
so first of all thank you uh those are
very kind words but
uh uh the truth is
we started probably like every other
journey with the
question about product marketplace and
as you as you probably understood
by now we had to shift or pivot like a
lot of people would say
in order to reach that um and and to
find something that the market demands
and then we would have to build a
product that would actually accommodate
those requests
and so we're very lucky in that sense
that we found it
i think or at least uh it seems so
and then your your position changes
because once you have that product
market fit
it's you really you have to execute on
the go to market
and so you have to start bringing in
people who will be better than you
with the sales because your position as
the sales leader
is is over you understand the product
you understand what you need to build
you understand how it it's going to grow
into the vision that
that you set out for the company or that
was sort of
uh crystallizing during that process
and then you have to bring in the right
people to do that execute the go to
market with them
um bring in people to to take care of
the product the way that
at least you you imagine it should be
but they all obviously they they have
uh their independence because they
they're closer
to the to the customers
and then you start thinking about two
things two things one is how do you
reach global domination and the second
is
at some point you you realize that that
sales motion is going to
to plateau because
you know it has its limits it uh
it might be part of a larger vision and
so you have to start
thinking of what's the next step so if
your cells start to
to go in the exponential way you want to
start hammering on that as much as you
can start
expanding to new markets new verticals
and so you're shifting to to marketing
and sales
rather than the product in r d that at
least i was very focused on
early on and right now it's
doing that as well as understanding okay
we are at the right end of the curve but
some
at some point it's going to uh to end
and we even need to be ready for that
with a new product that would start the
exponential growth
or at least the expend uh to expand that
so we started very small in our
messaging
talking about a single vm performance of
the single vm right now we're talking
about
maybe big data maybe api service
and maybe next level would also be
around
complete use cases how do we do that
through
healthcare how do you do that through
insurance and so on right and i have to
say that what i love about what you're
saying here is
on the one hand you're talking about all
this vision and this potential that
where you can take the product and you
can see yourself going in
four different verticals that are all
that all could mean so much
to granulate at the same time you're
you're prioritizing focus
and throughout this whole journey what
i'm hearing from you is that
you've had to prioritize and you had to
really be focused
on the specific segmentations that
you're building the products you're
building the the customer
and the product market fit and i assume
that it's a similar mentality for these
verticals as well and
assaf i want to thank you for spending
this time with me
20 minutes go by way way too fast i have
about 100 more questions here that i
want to ask
but at this point i just want to thank
you for being generous with your time
and for three words that you would use
to describe yourself
or if i would ask any of your co-founder
or
employees to what what who is a south
ezra
probably very mission driven
that would probably sum me up i love
those three words very mission driven
asap i can't wait to see where you take
granulate and i
i just love what you're doing i like
love the team that you're with i love
your story and i especially love the
fact that
from the moment that you started working
with your co-founder on one project to
when you actually formed the team
it was such a long period of time but i
think that that's really the core of
what a
what a good company is so thank you for
taking the time and stay safe and stay
healthy
thank you pleasure to be